when's the last time you actually used a
pencil Samsung is taking it literally
with the new range of tablet accessories
the pencil feels greatly in hand and it
does not need to be charged at all
partnering with Statler pencil feels
lighter and lacks the distinct weight of
the original but hey if you're still
able to pull off your sweet finger moves
cause these come in handy as an adult
the accessory also comes in the form of
a Monami mechanical pencil as well great
for those who love a feature device to
be handy at any time the iconic Lammy
pan design makes an appearance as well
it feels exactly like the original in
hand but similar to The Statler it is
also lighter overall to complete the
paperlight experience Samsung has their
own screen cover which replies the
texture of paper when used together with
the band it's a standalone accessory
that comes in two tints I'm guessing
that most people will actually go with
the white one what do you guys think of
this it's definitely a nice touch